For example, 1 0 1 0 indicates that orbitals 1 and three are occupied. These
measurements have been chosen for pedagogical reasons only. The resulting occupancies may not match a physical system. In physical contexts, it is
often the case that the system has a known total number of particles. There also may be other conservation laws that
you can leverage to determine the physicality of a measured state. To stay concrete, let's assume our system is
known to have a total particle number of n= 2. This tells us the total number of ones that should appear in our state
label, which is called a Hamming weight constraint.
However, some measured configurations violate this constraint. The state 1 0 1 0 is physically valid. But the state 1 1
1 0 has too many particles and the state of all zeros has too few particles. Zero
in fact. These violations can be due to noise in the system or errors in measurement. We need a way to get back
to configurations that make physical sense at least in an approximate way.
This is called configuration recovery.
To correct our noisy samples, we probabilistically flip bits in invalid configurations based on the average
orbital occupancy averaged over valid configurations.
Orbital occupancies are the expectation values of the number operator acting on each orbital. This is estimated and
refined self-consistently using the states produced from SQD. Let's look at orbital 2 for example. In two of the
four valid configurations, orbital 2 was occupied. This gives us an expected occupancy of 0.5.
We do the same for the other three orbitals. Now we return to an invalid configuration 1 1 0. We can flip one of
the bits from 1 to zero to generate a valid configuration. But which one should we flip? One way of deciding is
through the deviation of each orbital's occupancy from the averages we just calculated.
Here we see that the biggest difference is in the occupation of orbital one. So we might expect that bit one should be
flipped from a one to a zero. Of course, orbital 2 is not far behind. And it's always possible, however unlikely, that
this measured state is the result of multiple errors on the same state.
Choosing only the largest deviation from mean for all invalid states is not optimal. Instead, bits are flipped
probabilistically with the probability being a function of the differences shown here. Let us suppose that in this
case we do change the bit that differs the most from the average occupation. So 1 1 0 becomes 1 1 0 0. We would do the
same process for the other invalid choice. Let's say that in this case we end up flipping bits one and three.
After this correction process, we have a new set of configurations that might look like this.
Using this refined set, we can update the average orbital occupancy to improve fidelity. In our case, the new
occupancies are these.
This iterative recovery process ensures that noisy measurements are filtered into physically meaningful
configurations, improving the accuracy of igen state approximations in SQD. The SQD Kiskit add-on has some tools that
will be instrumental in this process. If we've done a good job sampling the states in the support of the true ground
state of the system, then we should be able to look at only the parts of the Hamiltonian that act on this subspace
and still obtain a good ground state and energy. In our trivially small 4 cubit example, there are initially 2 or 16
possible states of the system. Using a combination of sampling and configuration recovery, we reduce this
to three states in our subspace of interest. three states that we hope make up the support of the true ground state.
We now project our full Hamiltonian onto that subspace. That is we make a matrix M out of a column of vectors from our
recovered sampled subspace and an analogous one M dagger out of the rows and we multiply M dagger HM
pictorially. This means taking the matrix elements in the rows and columns corresponding to the states in our
recovered sampled subspace. The highlighted rows and columns are those corresponding to our subspace. And the
darker highlighted boxes where they overlap are the elements that we keep for our new projected matrix.
Now that we have selected out the subspace of interest, we can diagonalize this matrix on a classical computer
using a standard solver. If the true ground state is comprised entirely of states in our subspace, this
diagonalization should yield the correct ground state and ground state energy. If we merely have most of the ground state
support, we may get close. Once we've obtained the ground state for this projected Hamiltonian, we have a very
useful state from which to calculate the average occupancy of each orbital.
Previously, our occupancies were calculated from states that we sampled using an anzots that we hoped would help
us approach our ground state. But there was no guarantee that the average occupancy of each orbital from that sampling corresponded to the occupancy
in the lowest energy state. Let's back up. We had a sampling of computational states. We used configuration recovery
to correct any that were physically invalid. Then we calculated the average orbital occupancy using all of them. The
ground state might only include some of them. The ground state of this projected Hamiltonian may not be the true ground
state of our original system, but it is the lowest energy state that can be created using any superposition of the
recovered states in our subspace. The orbital occupancy of this state will yield an energy less than or equal to
the energy of the occupancy obtained from the recovered space. So this occupancy is a better estimate of our
ground state occupancy. We can repeat the configuration recovery process using this new occupancy and we can iterate
this until our convergence criteria are met. Sample-based quantum diagonalization is fast compared to
other near-term algorithms like VQE. It's more scalable and it is robust to noise and errors in sampling. It does
still require that we prepare a good onsance with a large projection under the support of the true ground state of our system. If nothing at all is known
about our true ground state, SQD may need to be used in conjunction with other methods to first learn about the
ground state and iteratively approach it.
SQD plays a critical role in the emerging suite of classical quantum hybrid algorithms and is one of the
greatest drivers toward useful quantum computing.